for this talk we are extremely lucky
this morning to have professor antonio
matero here to speak to us about
butterfly eye spots
professor montero has been working on
butterfly eye spots for 16 years now
she's looked at how they are made
looking at the genetics and the
developmental paradigms as well as the
function of eye spots and that's what
she's going to be talking about to us
today
to give you a little background on her
she started her interrupt with her
undergraduate degree at the university
of lisbon in portugal so she comes to us
from portugal did her phd in edinboro
and scotland and then did two post-docs
so this is study you do after your phd
at harvard and at the netherlands and
all of it was on butterfly eye spots
she also along the way had one daughter
who's with us today which is
tremendously exciting
and is now highly embarrassed and just
to give you a sense that as much as
science is phenomenal and we do it all
the time in every waking moment most of
us also do other things as well so to
give you a little flavor of that
professor matera also works with stained
glass mosaics and does oil painting
so with that thank you so much for
coming
okay
thank you aaron for the introduction um
can everybody hear me in the back is
this a good a good sound
okay good
um so i'm extremely pleased to be here
today to tell you about the subject that
i've been dedicating my life to it may
seem really small subject to you but
these eye spots really hold a lot of
mysteries in terms of
all kinds of things and what i'm going
to
tell you today today today is
some of the
functions of these
bullseye structures that
butterflies have on the edges of their
wings
and what is the purpose of these
structures what do they do
why do they vary in number and size
between different species of butterfly
and so
let's sort of get started can i probably
get the lights um in the
in the room just a little bit lower so
that we can see the slides just maybe
the ones in the front
or even
is that
something
so let's
let's sort of address this question
today why do butterflies have eyes or
they're really called eye spots not
really eyes but they look like eyes so
why do they have these eye spots on
their wings
and i'm going to address
i'm going to tell you about experiments
that my students and i have been doing
the past few years
to address whether i spot
for instance allow butterflies to
survive in the wild
better than butterflies that don't have
eye spots for instance
so do i spots have any kind of function
in interactions with predators for
instance
and the other question i'm sort of going
to be focusing on
is whether eye spots are also important
in communication between males and
females so whether they have some kind
of a role
in inter-specific communication meaning
in certain males sending out signals to
females females to males
and
have a sort of a role in what we call
sexual selection
so this is the diversity i mean part of
the diversity that we see in butterflies
um
they have different numbers of eye spots
so look at this wing here there's three
eye spots on the wing here there's a
tiny one on this pieces here these are
all different species of butterflies
sometimes they have different colors
in the rings around them
they appear in different positions on
the wing and so forth there's a lot of
variation in i spot number and i spot
size and i squat position
and
here are some experiments that we didn't
do ourselves in the lab but these are
some of the most interesting and sort of
clear experiments
that look at the role of eye spots
in interactions with predators
in this case we have a bird predator
um a tit
and what these experimenters what these
people have done and these experiments
were done in sweden in europe with this
european butterfly called the peacock
butterfly and this butterfly normally
has these big eye spots at the edges of
their wings
and so what adrian valen did
was in one set of experiments he asked
the question
if i put a bird in a cage with these
butterflies but if i cover
the eye spots on their wings with black
paint
what happens to
this butterfly compared with the
butterfly that also has paint applied on
its wings but not covering the eye spots
and so what he found was that
when birds approached these butterflies
that normally were sitting with their
eye spots hidden because these eye spots
are on the upper surfaces of the wings
and when the butterflies are resting
they sort of hide these eye spots when
the bird was approaching these
butterflies these butterflies open their
wings suddenly
actually make a hissing noise when they
feel that there's a predator approaching
and they rapidly display their eye spots
so
when the butterflies had their eye spots
still visible to the predator the
predator approached the butterfly the
butterfly opened and flashed its eye
spots and the bird flew away scared off
so he was startled by this response of
this insect and he decided that he was
not going to attack
however when the eye spots were painted
with the black paint
the birds
startled just a little bit and still
attacked the butterfly and ate most of
these butterflies were eaten in these
experiments but almost one butterfly out
of 30 was eaten when they had the eye
spots present on their swings so it
looks like
eye spots seem to have an important role
in interactions with bird predators in
this case and they are used in these
sort of startle type of defenses
in interactions with these birds
now our butterflies the ones we actually
rear here at yale have a slightly
different behavior so they actually
display eye spots in the exposed surface
of their wings when their wings are
closed
and they don't have this
behavior they don't display anything in
their dorsal surfaces they always just
sit there until they are attacked by a
predator so what's happening there so
here's a little movie of an attack
of a bird lizard whoops let me just go
back here
see if i can get this
so here's a lizard that has attacked the
margin of the wing of our butterfly
species that has a lot of eye spots on
the surface here and it's trying to grab
on to the big eye spot there on the way
and here's coming another one whoops
and it attacked
this one and this particular butterfly
is not going to escape so it's actually
going to be all gobbled up by this
lizard but the previous attack the
lizard attacked
this area here of the butterfly
preferentially
and actually that butterfly escaped
so the wing broke off in that position
where it was attacked by the lizard and
the butterfly actually flew away and
survived the attack and was still able
to fly and to continue laying eggs and
so forth so in this particular species
that does not have that type of flashing
behavior and the eye spots are always
exposed
at the edges of the wings they are
exposed to predators it looks like the
function is a little bit different eye
spots here instead of being startling
devices
to startle and sort of
scare off predators they are used to
deflect the attack of predators to the
wing margin so the predators attack the
wing
rather than the vulnerable body and so
the butterfly can survive and continue
to lay eggs so that's a different
function
for eye spots in different species of
butterflies
so this particular species of butterfly
is actually an interesting species it
has
two different wing patterns
in different times of the year
it's not the same
animal that changes its eye spots from
very small and almost
absent
in the dry season in africa this
butterfly comes from malawi from africa
and in malawi you have a dry
cool season so it's not the same as our
summers here our summers are usually dry
and hot
but in malawi you have dry and cool so
low temperatures
and then you have a wet
and warm season in africa and
the butterflies this is the same species
of butterfly it's
if you take caterpillars and if you take
eggs
coming out from one female and then you
separate those eggs and half of the eggs
you rear them at low temperature
and the other half of the eggs you rear
them at high temperature you get these
very different wing patterns appearing
on the wings of this one species of
butterfly
so this is what we call phenotypic
plasticity
sort of
one genome one type of
information one species but you can do
very different things to your wing
pattern depending on the environment and
in this case the rearing conditions
where the caterpillars are
are living in
and so
why is it why is it that this species
produces two very different wing
patterns
in the dry season in africa and in the
wet season in africa so why are ice
spots smaller here and why do i spots
get larger in the wet season
so
these experiments done with these two
seasonal forms were done also just like
the previous one with lizards
birds and lizards were used
to try and find out if there was any
difference in terms of the attacks of
these predators
towards these butterflies
and what they found was that
it doesn't really matter how big
the eye spots are on the wing
in interactions with birds and lizards
having tiny little pupils or small
little areas here small little patches
of black or in this case there's
in many cases these white scales are
also present although it's difficult to
see in the center of these eye spots it
doesn't matter the size of the eye spot
the birds and lizards will usually
attack the edges of the wings
and and so we couldn't figure out
why is it that the ice spots get bigger
in the wet season when when they're
small they're equally effective
in interactions with these two types of
predators
um
in the diverting the attack towards the
wing margin so it was a real puzzle
and the other thing that we found out is
that
if you put these butterflies in a cage
with birds and lizards
in fact they're much more difficult to
detect
than these butterflies so it's a real
puzzle
if
once they are detected so once these
butterflies are detected the attacks
also happen on the wing margin
but they are more difficult to detect so
why produce bigger eye spots it was
really sort of a difficult thing to
explain and so one of my postdocs in the
lab recently
decided
to try a different predator
so inserts of birds and lizards she she
thought that perhaps a different type of
predator with a different visual system
like praying mantises
could be involved in explaining the
different sizes of the eye spots in the
different seasons
so what katie did was she
placed butterflies one at a time in an
arena that she constructed sort of a
little arena the death arena
for these butterflies and so she would
put the butterfly in the arena and then
let the mantid crawl slowly towards the
butterfly and what she found was that
when mantids do that
they attack
the wing edges of this butterfly
but they attack the body of this
butterfly
so they attack the butterfly in
different areas depending on whether
they have big eye spots or no eye spots
at all or very tiny eye spots so these
predators actually attack butterflies
differently depending on whether they
are on the dry season
or the wet season form
so perhaps
these predators that only exist
in the wet season
time of the year
could be an important sort of predator
to explain
why eye spots become bigger and smaller
especially why they become bigger in the
wet season and not
remain small and cryptic throughout the
year because you have birds and lizards
present both in the dry season in the
wet season for them small eye spots are
sufficient to direct the attacks towards
the wing margin away from the body but
when you have these present predators
that are only present in half of the
year then it's better to have bigger eye
spots because these predators are
oriented towards bigger targets and they
attack there preferentially whereas they
attack more often the wing body if you
don't have those big targets to deflect
their attacks
so in summary for this part of the talk
it looks like eye spots can scare off
predators when they are displayed
suddenly so some species of butterflies
have that behavior but others don't
so eye spots can also be used to divert
the attacks of predators away from the
body
into the wing margin
in interactions with birds and lizards a
small ice pot is as efficient as a large
eye spot in doing that in diverting the
attacks
towards the wing margins
but
interactions with mantids a different
type of predator
large eye spots are more efficient in
deflecting the attacks
away from the body towards
the margin of the wing
and so it looks like in this one species
of butterfly that has different eye spot
sizes in different seasons of the year
it looks like they change the size of
their eye spots perhaps to match the
type of predators that exist at
different times of the year in these
forests in africa
okay so
let's move on and ask the question why
do different species of butterflies
have and moths in this case have
different number and size of eye spots
so you would think that if i spots are
important in deflecting the attacks into
the wing margin or deflect or
scaring off predators
there should be some kind of optimal
pattern optimal number of eye spots that
these butterflies and moths should all
converge on
to be able to function perfectly in
interactions with predators and yet
they vary all over the place there's
butterflies with different number of eye
spots different size of eye spots why do
we have all this diversity
and here's an example so here's the same
picture just showed you butterflies
usually have a large number of eye spots
on their wings and they vary in number
but plots also have eye spots on their
wings and they usually have them hidden
by the four wings and they usually just
have a single eye spot on each wing
surface you never see multiple eye spots
in the wings of moths so it's only
one of them and it's usually quite large
so
why do we have all of this eye spot
number diversity
so let me tell you about some
experiments that we didn't do either in
the lab but a person called martin
stevens in england did these experiments
and what he did was he used paper models
and this is something that you could
actually do yourself uh if you wanted to
try this at home
it's safe
you can try this at home so what he did
was he cut off pieces of paper these are
gray little triangles of paper that he
printed out on the computer
and some triangles and they kind of
mimic a moth as it's sitting in the tree
of a trunk of a tree
and in some pieces of paper he put one
big eye spot pattern in the middle
and in other pieces of paper he put many
little small eye spot patterns
so he was trying to figure out
what is the sort of
the reason for all of these different
eye spots
number diversity that we see in
lepidoptera there's one eye spot or two
perhaps because two
kind of mimics the head of a big
predator like of a big vertebrate animal
like
i don't know an owl or
something that is scarier than perhaps a
small tiny butterfly with tiny little
eyes in the front
so if you have two does this work better
than just having one
or three so here you'd have something
like an eye mimic butterflies having two
eye spots that mimic the head of
something bigger
but here there's no animal that really
has three eye spots in a row so you're
not really imitating the head of
anything but you have three of these so
what works better and so he tried all
kinds of combinations and in order to
to test
the role of these uh the role of the
interactions of these paper things
with predators he allured lord predators
to come and predate on these patterns by
putting a little mealworm a munchie a
sort of a larva in the middle
in the on top of these pieces of paper
there was something that the birds
wanted a little mealworm
attached to each one of these pattern
elements
so he put hundreds and hundreds of these
things in trees all over cambridge uh in
the forests there and he came back every
single day and he checked how many of
the will mealworms had been predated had
been eaten
from each one of these different
patterns
and so what he found was the following
he found that these two
patterns the meal worms stay there the
longest
so birds or whatever predators he did
not know what was eating these things
whatever predators were approaching to
get the mealworm they were not
approaching these patterns as often as
they were approaching the others
and this one was also just as good there
was really no statistical significant
difference between the time the the
number of these that still had the
mealworm and these two
so what's special about these three
relative to the other three
any any ideas there
go ahead
yes
these ones this one is bigger these two
are together are also just as big
and these three in fact together are
just as big so if you actually sum up
the area
of all of these circles together the
area of these three circles together is
exactly the same as the area of this one
and the area of these two is the same as
the area of that
but these two have a smaller combined
area as these and this one has a smaller
combined area as those are those
so
it looks like
having one big eye spot
or having multiple small eye spots seem
to be just as good
just as efficient in driving off
predators or sort of uh making predators
suspicious of what these patterns are
and preventing them from coming in and
grabbing the mill worm so they are sort
of a little scared by either one big
spot or three smaller spots they are
just as effective
and so it looks like if you go back to
this diversity
of patterns that you see in the wings of
moths and butterflies
perhaps
having one big one or having multiple
small ones
is just as effective in interactions
with predators
and perhaps if you
if you change the relative sizes of your
eye spots and eliminate some eye spots
from the wings so to give more space for
the others to appear perhaps you are
also
equally um
effective in scaring off
predators and so this was this was the
worst pattern all the mealworms were
eaten up from these little triangles of
paper and these ones were the next worst
okay so this is as far as i a story that
i have for you in terms of
the function of eye spots in
interactions with predators
but now let's sort of look at what eye
spots do
in interactions between males and
females so
here's kendra she was one of my students
and she asked this question
are eye spot patterns also used in
interactions between males and females
of the same species
and so here's a
a male over here and a female that are
mating and and this is the species that
we have in the lab so males and females
mate like this they find each other they
decide they want to mate and they mate
with each other
and we ask kendra asked
are males are our females looking at the
eye spots in the males
and
are they sort of choosing who to mate
with because of their wing patterns
because of the males having these
beautiful eye spots on their wings
do they select a mate based on the
colors
that these males display
and so she did a series of experiments
we did not know
what the females like we cannot ask a
butterfly tell me do you like the eye
spots on the mail we cannot ask this
question of a butterfly because they
don't
speak right they don't answer
so what we do is we do experiments and
the experiments that we do is
we put a female butterfly in the cage
and we put that female with two males
and we change the pattern
on each of the males
we sometimes we
vary the size of the males for instance
in a cage we put a small male and a big
male
and then we see who the female likes so
we make an experiment and the answer is
given to us by the female because we ask
her who do you like to mate with do you
like the big male or do you like the
small male and so we observe who the
female picks as a mate and then we know
she likes this or she doesn't like this
or she doesn't care okay
so when we did a small male and a big
male and this is the number of times
that we did this experiment every time
we used a different female and two
different males one small one big
and 27 times out of 50 the female liked
to mate with a big male but 23 times out
of female out of 50
the female mated with a small male so
females don't really care
how big the male is they half of the
time they mate with a big male half of
the time with a small male so that
doesn't seem to be important at all for
females they don't care about the size
of the male now what about eye spots do
they care about the size of the eye
spots
so here we did another experiment we put
a female in a cage with two males one
had
small eye spots on their exposed surface
in the ventral surface and the other
male had large eye spots
and if you look at the times that they
mated with each and the other it doesn't
look like they care about the size of
these ventralized spots
they don't care the male can have big
eye spots small eye spots females don't
look at that
okay do they look at the number of eye
spots that the males have so here's the
mutation that we have in our lab eye
spots here are missing in the hind wing
and
females don't care about how many eye
squats males have
they're just as happy mating with this
mutant with fewer eye spots than a male
that has the complete row
what about these pupils
so if we block these pupils with a
little bit of black paint if we paint
these pupils off
these are sort of very bright white
little pupils in the center of the eye
spot do they care
they mate it just as nicely with
males that have no pupils relative to
males that have pupils about half the
time so females don't seem to care at
all about
the eye spots that are exposed
to predators
and on the ventral side of the wing
now let's look at the other side of the
wing the dorsal the hidden surface of
the wings okay
so we looked at the size of these eye
spots on the hidden surface of the wings
so these are eye spots that are not
exposed to predators
and perhaps have a role in communication
between males and females but they don't
seem to care much about the size
of these eye spots
and we remove the gold ring
from some of the eye spots they don't
seem to map to care either they made 26
times with males without the gold ring
with the gold ring
so
can you imagine kendra doing 50
experiments at a time and not finding
anything it's very frustrating right i
mean i would have given up by now but
she didn't so she continued
so here she found something
she then took out the pupils
on the dorsal surface of the eye spot
and look what she found here
34 of the trials
the females mated with the males that
had these white pupils on the dorsal
surface
and only 16 times almost half as much
the females mated with the males that
did not have those pupils
so it looks like having a pupil is good
females like that
so finally at
experiment number 13 whenever she found
something she found that these pupils in
the dorsal surface of the eye spots
females like them
females like these pupils in the males
and so when you find something like this
then you sort of
go a little bit further you ask the
question okay
if we reduce the pupil do the female
scare so she painted half of the pupil
away
and
females seem to mate just as well with
males with reduced pupils or with
complete pupils that didn't seem to
faze them too much but if you enlarge
the pupil with this sort of correcting
fluid that you use to correct mistakes
in your homework
if you use that little white fluid that
also is quite uv reflective it has the
same sort of properties as the scales of
these butterflies
if you do that females don't like that
at all so they mate preferentially with
males that have the normal size people
they don't like enlarged pupils they
don't like that
so
they don't mind small pupils but they
don't like very big pupils so they like
the males just the way they are just the
way they are is fine perfect
so there is what we call stabilizing
selection for the size of the
the
these pupils and then what we did was we
blocked out
the pupils not with black paint but with
a substance
that allows the pupils to be continue to
be white
that eliminates their uv reflectivity uv
is a color that we cannot see but that
butterflies can see i'm going to show
you an experiment how that was done
in a minute um
but all of these experiments what they
concluded
is that female so that's the pink
outline butterfly over there
they like male the blue guys over here
with pupils on their dorsal surface that
seems to be the only thing females care
about in terms of eye spots on the wings
of males and they like these pupils
because they are uv reflective let me
show you this experiment how we do these
experiments in the lab
if i can get my my little thing
so this is a repeat of an experiment
that kendra did this is a male
and these are these little white pupils
that they have on the hidden surfaces of
their wings
and here's a
a uv camera that shows that these eye
spots are extremely bright in the uv
and here's a male trying to court with a
female it goes around and it flashes its
wings really fast right next to the eyes
of the female so that's the time when
females can actually see
the eye spots the inner hidden eye spots
of males
and here's i'm applying this solution
rutin
you put it on top of the pupils
it's they remain white but the uv is
eliminated you see there's no uv signal
anymore so when the males flash their
wings there's no uv coming through
and here we're doing the choice
experiments i'm putting a male and two
um
two males and one female in one cage
and then
we ask the female who she mates with so
the males try to court with the female
and the female ultimately makes their
choice i like to mate with the males
that have those uv reflective pupils on
their wings and so this is how all of
those experiments were done in a sort of
a similar
similar way
okay um
now here's the interesting thing so
these experiments showed
that females don't care at all about the
size the number of eye spots that
males display
on the exposed surface of their wings
and as we saw before the exposed surface
of the wings are the ones that predators
care about
and these are the eye spots that are
involved in interactions with birds and
lizards and mantids in different times
of the year
so what's happening
to the dorsal surface of these
dry seasons butterflies and wet season
butterflies
nothing is happening to them so the eye
spots remain the exact same size
in the dry season and in the wet season
and so we think that um because
these structures these eye spots they
vary in size
in the exposed surface to better adapt
the butterfly to the different types of
predators that exist in each season
but these eye spots because they are
used in sexual selection in
communication between males and females
and they mate both in this season and
that season these eye spots stay exactly
the same size they do not change
predators don't seem to see them the
only function that these eye spots serve
is to um
communicate and sort of help females
make decisions about who they want
to mate with
now here's a sort of a strange
thing
so we have so this is a photograph of
these uv reflective pupils in the center
of the eye spots and here's the female
and here's the the male and this is the
dorsal surface
and this is the ventral surface
so we did all of these experiments
from the females perspective we said
what do females like and we did all of
these manipulations putting
males of each type
and asking females alone what they liked
but we haven't asked males what they
like
do males also
have a preference perhaps
here's sort of what's
strange about it if females like
the pupils in males
and if that is important it explains why
males have these dorsal pupils
but as you see here females also have
eye spots on the dorsal surface of their
wings
now why do females have eye spots
do males like to mate with females that
have eye spots as well
so males have eye spots and we know why
they have them because females like them
but females also have these dorsal eye
spots why do they have them
do males also pick females or are
females the only choosy
member here
sexier
so do males also care about the presence
of dorsalis spots in females
and do butterflies of the wet season and
dry season
make the same choices
so this is the experiment that katie
again
decided to do
so
we are intrigued we have
we know females like those eye spots in
males but females also carry them
so do males
make a choice so we did the exact same
type of experiments that we did before
this time we only manipulated those
pupils because we thought okay that's
the important thing
let's see if males also like
prefer to mate with females that have
these pupils so here's the reverse type
of experiment we have a male in blue
we put a male in the cage and then we
give them two females okay
and now the females some of them have
the pupils half of them have the pupils
and the other half don't the same exact
experiment but now asking males what
they like and if we ask males of the wet
season
they don't care
they mate just as well with females with
pupils or females without pupils
so
it doesn't look like males care at all
but the pattern of the female looks like
in the wet season
but now let's do the experiment with the
dry season males remember in the other
season in africa these males come out
they look like this
and if you give these males a choice
between the wet season with females with
pupils and females without pupils
they prefer to mate with females with
pupils
so they really prefer these females and
they don't like these females anymore
so there's something odd going on
males at one time of the year don't care
what the wing pattern of the female
looks like
but males at the different time of the
year they really care what the female
looks like
that's very strange
now
the dry season females we hadn't tested
them either we'd only done all of these
experiments with wet seasoned females
so when we now do the experiments with
the dry season females and we manipulate
the pupils in males
now they don't care anymore about what
the males have on their wings so dry
seasoned females we do these
manipulations and they mate just as
nicely just as well with males with
pupils and males without pupils so this
is all very wacky
there's sort of all kinds of changes and
the choosy choosinesses of of these
butterflies vary tremendously from one
season in africa to the other season in
africa
so here's sort of the summary of what we
found
is that
in the dry season when the ventral
surface looks like this
and the dorsal surface looks like this
males are the choosy sex
males are the ones that decide what they
like
they are in control they are in the
driver's seat
females try to mate with equal with with
these males but males are the ones that
ultimately decide
who they want to mate with and they make
that decision
based on the presence of these dorsal
eye spots in females
but in the wet season females are the
choosy sex
females decide who they want to mate
with
and they prefer to mate with eye spots
with males that have the pupils
on their dorsal surface
now why is that
why does the choosy sex vary
from the males being the choosy sex in
one part of the year
and the females being the choosy sex in
the other part of the year
it's very intriguing
we don't know but here's here's
something that we do know
we know that if females
if they are of this type
sorry if male a females mate with a male
of a dry season
these males when they mate with a female
they give her a lot of nutrients
so they give her a sort of a
they pass on sperm to fertilize her eggs
but in addition they give females a lot
of nutrients
during copulation when they're mating
they pass on lots of fats and and
sugars and things like that at the same
time that they give them sperm
and if a female mates with one of these
males the female lives twice as long
as if it not had not made it at all
or if it had mated with one of these
males
so
males seem to be
contributing to the longevity or to the
ability of female to survive during the
dry season
when they're not really busy laying eggs
because it's the dry season there's no
grasses available for them to lay eggs
all the females have to do is
store nutrients sit quietly on the
forest floor and wait until the rain
comes and then they start laying eggs
and when the rains come and the grasses
and sprout in the forest floor
and so females are actually quite busy
we think
trying to actually elicit courtship from
males so they are the ones that start
harassing the males they start going
after the males displaying their wing
patterns so doing the exact opposite of
what males normally do to females and
what you saw in the movie females are
the ones that start harassing males
displaying their wing pattern
showing them their eye spots
and trying to get males to give them
food
because what they really want from males
not is not just the sperm they want the
food that males can give them that can
help them survive through the dry season
until they can lay eggs again in the wet
season
and so
males at that time
they are in possession of the food
and they say okay show me your wing
pattern and let me see if you're
of my species
and essentially what we think these eye
spots are doing is that they're
communicating
um whether
a certain butterfly is of the right
species because there's a lot of
variation in presence or absence of
these dorsalis but in other species of
the same group that live in the same
forests in africa
and so for the males
to be able to release their their food
they want to make sure that they're
mating with a female of their own
species and so they wait for the females
to display their wing pattern then they
say okay you are of my own species
here's the nutrients
but they don't want to give those
nutrients to a female of a different
species that may also want nutrients
just to survive through the dry season
they sort of have to make that sort of
chick okay you have two pupils on the
surface of your wings on the dorsal
surface you're of my species i'll give
you the nutrients and the spermatophores
but in the wet season
males don't really give nutrients to
females there's a lot of fruits and
bananas and things like that lying
around in the forest
and so
the females are the ones that become the
choosy sex
the females uh want to make sure that
they're mating with the right male of
their own species and then males are the
ones that have to display their wing
patterns and say look i'm your species
i'm your species i have two eye spots uh
mate with me
and so females become the choosy sex in
the wet season but males are the choosy
sex in the dry season
and so this is sort of just a summary of
what i've just told you
um the pattern on the dorsal surface
that these butterflies have is probably
involved in species recognition
males don't want to mate with the wrong
species when they carry this nutritious
what we call spermatophores
which is only in the dry season
and so they make but males mate with
anything they're really ready to mate
with anything in the wet season because
they don't really have anything to lose
sperm is very cheap to produce
and
now females don't care about mating with
the wrong species in the dry season so
much because they do want to survive
through the dry season and they really
only want the food that the males can
give them
um but they do care about mating with
the correct species in the wet season
when they when they are the ones that
are now investing a lot into the
next generation investing nutrients in
egg laying
and just sort of for you to remember
this
it's kind of interesting that um
we normally think of sexually selected
traits traits like these eye spots in
the feathers of peacocks
as being
traits that are only displayed by one
sex but not the other sex so in peacocks
it's the male
that has these beautiful feathers and
the p hen the female has is a drab dull
looking bird
but in butterflies it's in our species
at least it's quite interesting
both of these
males and females both of them have
these dorsal light spots
so you don't have a situation like this
with the drab female and a good looking
male when here in this species the
female only makes the decision of who
she mates with and she only mates with
good looking males
in butterflies both males and females
choose each other
and they select the wing patterns of
each other but they do that in different
times of the year and they select on
exactly the same eye spots but they do
it in one season
the females pick the males and in the
other season the males pick the females
and so you don't have
a pattern of sexual dimorphism males
looking different from females they
actually look very similar and yet you
have strong sexual selection happening
in in these species
okay my sort of final
final point here is going to be
going back to sort of the i spot number
diversity
we talked a little bit about how i spots
can trade off between being very large
and having fewer few of them on the wing
and being very small and had
many appearing on the wing so that type
of trade-off can happen because both
having one big one or many small ones
are equally effective
in interactions with predators but what
about
males and females do they also care
about the number of eye spots that these
butterflies have on the wing and so we
asked that question and these
experiments were done by andrea a
graduate student here at yale
so she asked
if species have different number of eye
spots
do females also care about the number of
eye spots that the male has on its wings
and and how the females
if they do care how can you sort of move
over and sort of one species
prefers
perhaps two eye spots why does another
species now prefer three how do you make
the switch how do you sort of make
females
perhaps evolve
different preferences in different
species how does that happen
so here's an experiment that andrea did
so
she asked the question so we had we know
already that females prefer
males that have these
eye spot pupils on their wings
but look at this mutant we have a mutant
called spotty in the lab
and this mutant has four spots on the
wing instead of the normal two
so what andrea asked was
we know they like pupils and if we can
if we turn them off
females don't like to mate with those
males but do they care about how many
pupils the males have on their wings
so if we do an experiment where we put a
female in a cage
and we give a female a choice between a
male with two pupils or a male with four
pupils do the females care about the
number of pupils and eye spots that they
have on their wings
so we ask what is the innate preference
of a female
and
if you put a female in pink here
with these two males and you do the
experiment over and over and over again
you find out that females actually
prefer males with just two pupils which
is the normal pattern for this species
so 26 times they mated with males with
two people and 14 times only they mated
with males that have four pupils
so they prefer to mate with the
wild-type males
now
what happens
if
we train a female to like a new pattern
how do you do that
let's say that
a female comes out of its cocoon
it's hanging on the cage sort of drawing
its wings and so forth
and normally the females do not mate on
the first day that they come out of the
cocoon they are too fragile the wings
are soft they are just sitting there for
about 24 hours the whole day they cannot
mate however
males
can try to elicit courtship i mean they
can
try and convince females to mate with
them
and they do that by approaching these
females and flashing their wings and
displaying their dorsal wing patterns
so we did andrea did the following
experiment
she put
a female a very young female that had
just emerged that same morning
and she put that female in
a cage
with um
different types of males so the question
that she asked was does exposure
to a novel wing pattern on the first day
of a female's life
does that
influence her preference when she then
becomes sexually mature on days three
four five etc
when she can actually mate
so
in the first day a female was put in a
cage with a slightly older male that
tried to court the female and displayed
swing patterns to the female
and then at the end of the day the male
was removed from the cage and the female
was left alone again
and so we exposed females both to
the normal winged wing pattern the wild
type pattern
and to a novel wing pattern which is the
spotty wing pattern the spotty nails
and then we took these males off so each
female was only exposed to either the
wild type wing pattern or to the spotty
wing pattern in the first day of their
lives so when we did that and then she
on days three to eight she placed that
female in a cage with two males
and she gave a choice between the
wild-type male and a squatty male these
are two new males that she had never
seen before
so when she does that again
she concludes that the females continue
to prefer the wild-type male
if they are exposed to wild-type males
on the first day of their lives
however
if females are exposed to
spot emails
on the first day of their lives
their innate preference changes they
become influenced by what they see on
the first day of their lives
so
if a female was exposed to a spotty male
when she is just emerging from a cocoon
she now
almost has no as a slightly
a slightly sort of a slight preference
to mate with spotty males instead of
wild-type males
so
a female's preference for a particular
wing pattern in its own species is very
plastic it's not fixed
genetically determined it sort of can be
influenced by what they see
in the first day of their lives
and so this is very interesting
um it sort of suggests that
novel wing patterns
something that the female has never seen
so if there are mutations that
start
producing more wing spots like we
observed in our lab population
these mutations can actually become
preferred wing patterns simply if they
are seen by a naive female in the first
day of their lives
and perhaps
if
if we can think about it sort of
in longer terms in evolution if a
learned preference
can then somehow become a fixed
preference
and this we don't understand very well
how that happens genetically but let's
assume that first a female learns
something and if it keeps learning the
same thing over and over and over in
subsequent generations perhaps later on
her innate preference changes perhaps
she now prefers innately to mate with
spot emails instead of wild type nails
but we don't understand how that
transition could be made but perhaps if
that transition can be made
this type of plastic learning that
insects have
can facilitate the evolution of eye spot
number variation in butterflies
and so this is my final slide and i'll
just conclude i'll give you a sort of a
summary of the different things that we
covered today
it looks like eye spots why do
butterflies have eye spots on their
wings
they'd have them and the eye spots serve
two different functions in nature eye
spots seem to be important in
interactions with predators birds
lizards and insect predators like mantis
so they are important um
either in deflecting the attacks away
and
away from the body into the wing margin
or they are could be used as startling
devices to frighten away predators when
they approach
and it looks like our species by cyclist
aninana
uses these same eye spots for these um
and also sorry so to conclude so they
they are important in the interactions
with predators and also
in
male and female communication so they
are important in natural selection and
in sexual selection
and it looks like our species by
cyclozanina
uses these eye spots on different
surfaces of the wings for these
different functions
so the eye spots that are exposed when
the butterflies at rest
they seem to be important in
interactions with predators
and the eye spots that are on the
undersides of the wings sort of in the
hidden parts of the wings they seem to
be important in interactions between
males and females
and
it looks like our the species can change
the size of its exposed eye spots in
different seasons
and the reason why it does that is
because there are different predators
present
in one season in africa versus the other
season in africa and the butterflies are
trying to maximize
their ability to survive in each one of
these seasons
and by manipulating eye spot size you
can do that very well
okay
and it looks like it's a species that
unlike peacocks where the female is drab
and the male has beautiful eye spots on
its feathers
butterflies both males and females have
these eye spots on their dorsal surface
of their wings
because
males choose females and females choose
males and they look at the same eye
spots on the same surface of the wings
but they do it in different times of the
year
so it's an example of a species where
there's strong sexual selection
on the same wing patterns at different
times of the years by both sexes and
like peacocks when it's only the females
that care about what the males have
and it looks like an imprinting sort of
a learned mechanism that females
apparently have
can
facilitate perhaps the evolution of eye
spot number
on the wings of butterflies because
what females prefer is not a fixed thing
they can actually change their
preference depending on what they see
on the first day of their lives and that
learning mechanism may perhaps
facilitate the evolution of i spot
number
diversity in butterflies
and so the the experiments that i
mentioned here today were mostly done by
these three people katie prudick andrea
hodgins davis and kendra robertson who
worked with me in the lab and they are
the people that sort of provided a lot
of the data that i um
explained to you today and i'll take any
questions for you from you thanks very
much for your attention